my grandfather this is what one of the
things I talk about in the book he
criticized the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan much like people are now in
Russia criticizing the Russian invasion
of Ukraine and he was immediately fired
from his job his wife was fired from her
job their children that's my father and
my aunt were kicked out of University
for one comment that he made in private
I wrote the book before the invasion of
Ukraine but people who've read it now
that the preface essentially predicts
what has happened
when the powerful forces that hold the
current world order together
abdicate their responsibility or abstain
from that responsibility then other
people will attempt to fill that void I
think to remind people most of all that
what we have in the west the the freedom
the prosperity these they didn't fall
out of the sky they're not random
occurrences
the problem we've got is
if you change the language you can
change the laws without legislating and
and that's really the biggest problem if
you if you have laws that say people
must be uh safe right that law is there
to prevent violence against people but
if you change the meaning of the word
safety you've now got a law that is the
law against the people having the wrong
opinions in public the idea that you
must force people to be equal is evil
whether you're looking at it through the
lens of class or race or sex or gender
or whatever other [ __ ] people have
come up with and the reason it's evil is
not that it's not a good thing to
redistribute wealth and income from one
group of people to another it's the
amount of tyranny that it takes to
achieve is inevitably going to lead to
millions of people being killed as it
has done every time it's been tried
foreign
thank you very much indeed for coming to
this Bookshop Barney my name is Austin
Williams I'm the director of the future
cities project and this is a special
Barney in association with the
trigonometry and of course the Battle of
ideas it's a curious setup in the round
you have to excuse my back to some
members of the audience and vice versa
um so this uh Barney if you haven't been
to one before it's kind of like uh
hopefully an engaging conversation with
an author about their book them to
explain to you uh what they've written
why they've written it and the ideas
behind it this one is looking at
constant kiss in this book and
immigrant's love letter to the west and
with a touch of marketing genius it came
out just as the war started
um I'll actually if you look now in the
news the Russia says it's losing lots of
conscripts to the war and last week
there was a general General Oleg JF was
killed
but this book won't cost you an army and
an Oleg
uh it's only 14 quid
um
there's another one coming hang on
um so if this one's not about Russia
actually there's a session tomorrow when
Russia Constantine's already done a
session on Ukraine this is about kind of
British values British values which are
under attack and in some ways need to be
defended uh in it Constantine says uh
Freedom human rights tolerance peace and
prosperity must be guarded and never
taken for granted and the times uh
congratulated you on the book but then
did criticize you for not defining what
constitutes the west and I kind of
thought if the times doesn't realize
what the West is then we've got a bigger
problem maybe than even we thought
um Constantine is a podcaster and
together with Francis Foster he was in
the last session he's a co-creator of
trigonometry show which has half a
million subscribers
that is the sort of reaction I'm working
that's the kind of that's the only
payment you can afford exactly uh anyway
constantly is a translator writer social
commentator and is described as a Jewish
Russian British comedian
which is a bit like one of those kind of
jokes that you a Russian and a bird walk
into a bar
wait for it Brit says the bridge says
I'm kind of I'm tired and thirsty could
I have a beer
the Russian says I'm tired and thirsty
could I have a vodka the Jew says I'm
tired and thirsty could I have diabetes
anyway
um it goes downhill from here right so
it's a really the main thing is it's a
really enjoyable book if you haven't
read it it's on the book stand I
thoroughly thoroughly recommend it
really really insightful book and very
challenging as it happens
um it's available on the bookstore uh so
please go and get a copy the way the
Barney works is simply that I allow
Constantine to do maybe a five minute
introduction or as near to five minutes
we can get
um then I've got a whole series of
questions which I've derived from
reading the book
um which hopefully will allow
Constantine to draw out some of the more
themes actually if you haven't read it
you'll understand it maybe a little bit
more and then we come out to you the
audience for your questions and comments
on what you've heard and what you've
read yes and more broadly so with no
further Ado can we welcome please
constantly kissing
foreign
people clapping as well uh thank you for
that introduction I uh one thing I I
like disagreeing with people so I'll
immediately disagree with you in that
you say the book is not about the war
and of course it isn't but the main
contention of the book is that what
frankfuradi who I just did a session
with on Ukraine talks about which is
what he calls the West's moral
disarmament and that is the complete
loss of belief in our values in the fact
that they're important in fact frankly
that they even exist the idea that
there's such a thing as British values
or Western values is now uh something
that a lot of people question and my
contention is and has been from day one
and of course I wrote the book before
the invasion of Ukraine but people
who've read it know that the preface
essentially predicts what has happened
because it is in my view inevitable that
if the West weakens itself morally
economically militarily the and the the
the the law of history is very clear
when when the powerful uh forces that
hold the current world order together
abdicate their responsibility or abstain
from that responsibility then other
people will attempt to fill that void so
he it's unfortunately uh because the
situation Ukraine is obviously very
tragic uh but it is unfortunately a very
timely book if I say so myself
um but the the point of the book is I
think to remind people most of all that
what we have in the west the the freedom
the prosperity these they didn't fall
out of the sky they're not random
occurrences they're the product of
centuries of intellectual debate of
actual war of of endless battles in
order to attempt to work out what is a
better way of governing than the way of
governing that exists in most of the
rest of the world including the country
from which I come which is a strong man
leader comes in uh kills or imprisons
anyone they don't agree with and then
they rule for as long as they can
sustain that we've gone beyond that in
the west uh that seems to me to be a
better way of doing things and I'd quite
like people in the west to remember that
and to be willing to defend that so I
wanted to write an immigrant is love
alerted to the west to remind people
that
um
particularly young people who maybe
haven't traveled very much you haven't
seen much of the rest of the world
who've grown up in comfort and
prosperity uh who who don't really
appreciate what we have here how rare it
is how unique it is and therefore how
worthy of Defending and protecting it is
um and that that's that's the Crux of
the book very good very good uh on that
basis I'm sure you'd all know want to
buy it but let me just ask a couple of
questions if you if you will
um the gist of the book I'll just take a
couple of quotes and throw them back at
you see what you think or maybe you can
just develop the point so you say um
over the past few decades ever since
post-modernism moral relativism and
multiculturalism became a thing
intellectuals and academics brackets
many who buy into the soviet-style
theory have promoted destructive
Fashions as a result the West has lost
all self-confidence in his own values
and so that undermining of of cultural
norms I think we probably all recognize
I was just wondering whether you were
positing that this was a destabilization
from without or whether it's actually
happening from within how do you yes
yes it's both uh it's both and and you
cannot destabilize a society from
without unless that Society wants to
destabilize itself uh so the external
forces that would seek to capitalize on
the Discord and the divisiveness that we
have in the west China Russia Etc
they've been putting a lot of money into
bot Farms that amplify these supposed
divisions in Western Society but if
those divisions weren't there uh the the
those efforts would be completely futile
so we we've done this to ourselves and
then of course our enemies will want to
take advantage of that uh and that and
that's what I I think it's a combination
of those two things as we make ourselves
weaker opportunistic adversaries will
take advantage I understand that give us
but give us a little bit of background
as to how you think that kind of because
I don't necessarily buy into the many
who buy into the service style Theory I
don't necessarily think that's a driver
but how is this kind of moral relativism
it's a big question but how has it
really occurred
snapshot I don't know that I I know the
answer to that question I don't know how
I think it's a very complicated thing I
mean one of the people we interviewed on
trigonometry recently is a woman called
Louise Perry who has a book called the
case against the sexual Revolution I
think her Central argument is that the
technological advances of the central or
the sexual Revolution uh altered the
dynamic between men and women and
therefore changed the the status and
role of family and and many other things
and I think a lot of this is
technological
um the the development of social media
has taken those uh
ideas particularly ideas of the sort of
progressive left they have an advantage
online uh because they sound good and
they feel good they feel so good
equality and diversity and all of this
stuff it sounds a lot better than I
don't know closed Borders or you know
meritocracy these these things have a
different ring to them and and so these
technological changes that we've seen
they amplify some of the directions of
travel that I think are unhealthy for
Western Society because we're no longer
able to argue for the things that
actually represent British values or
Western valleys I a fair point so like
the chapter on language and uh
undermining or destruction of certain
kind of words and meanings is really
really interesting and you know there's
diversity there's gender there's all
that kind of stuff we know about even as
you say progressive or even left wing
right I mean what do we mean by these
things so again
I suppose how as a linguist how do we
deal with that do we try to reclaim some
of these words right you know I think
I'm Progressive right I wrote a book on
progress
um yet if you say that today it's meant
to be you know something else so do we
reclaim these words or do we give them
up as lost and try to formulate new
ideas and new ways of expressing
ourselves well again yes we have to
reclaim or uh you know the word woke I
think is a very interesting one because
obviously we all know it started out as
a self-descriptor of people who thought
that they were on the right side of
history and blah blah blah and then
people like me started mocking it and
then it became a drug determined now
it's kind of got to a point where I
don't really use the word work because I
just think it's tarnished by all sorts
of things so these these linguistic
battles were always gone my first
invitation to people is first of all to
recognize what is happening with
language so for example I always like to
use this example the the term inclusion
uh this is one or and safety these are
words that have meanings inclusion means
that people are included yet what we'll
find in a modern inclusive space is
quite a lot of people like me and you
would be excluded from them or if we
talk about something like safety safety
means the absence of physical violence
yet safety now means that no one
disagrees with your opinion
um so it is to notice these things and
then the problem we've got is if you
change the language you can change the
laws without legislating and and that's
really the biggest problem if you if you
have laws that say people must be uh
safe right that law is there to prevent
violence against people but if you
change the meaning of the word safety
you've now got a law that is a law
against the people having the wrong
opinions in public so the first thing I
think is we've got to be aware of it and
then yes culturally satiris and you know
podcasts and whoever can play with these
other terms and make them terms of
ridicule so people can no longer have
that Shield of virtue when they're
talking about being woke while advancing
some very aggressive ideas okay because
you're always done by the tolerant isn't
it the most tolerant people are
intolerant of me and you are you tired
of using bulky old wallets giving you a
bulge where you don't want it to be my
old wallet was massive so it brought all
the ladies to the yard which was a huge
distraction and got in the way of my
esteemed work on trigonometry reg
wallets have an incredible solution for
you this is mine Sleek stylish and with
an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anthem has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Ridge is so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
let me move on on in terms of um the
Russia story you say compared to Russia
we have a free and honest media
low bar
um but and matter of fact there is a
kind of a debate to be had as to whether
we do have a free and honest Media or no
we don't but compared to Russia we do
well compared to you know yeah compared
to Russia China looks good but I mean
the the point is is that are you letting
the West Off The Hook by making those
low bar comparisons well I think anyone
who follows my work knows that I'm not
exactly a big fan of the mainstream
media and I've been very critical about
many of the things in fact there's a
whole chapter in the book which is a
sort of reproduction of a long Twitter
thread that went uh quite viral during
the pandemic in which I talk about how
misrepresentation false messaging on
that issue and on many previous issues
has destroyed our faith in the media
which now means that people you know
there's there's this kind of online meme
of I support the current thing and now
there's the I oppose the current thing
and people will blindly believe or
disbelieve things simply because the
stream is advancing them but people also
should not be confused when we talk
about societies like Russia and China
there is a difference between a media
landscape which is increasingly
misrepresentative and not entirely
accurate and people choosing and picking
what they want to hear and the society
like China or Russia in Russia for
example there is no Independent Media
anymore everything is State controlled
um 80 of the Russian public get their
news from television and that is
entirely controlled by one man and his
cronies who are able to enforce a
particular vision of reality on the rest
of society so this is kind of the issue
that I address with the whole book which
is yes we have problems in the west yes
we're not perfect yes some of the ways
that our institutions have allowed
themselves to be degraded over time are
really really bad and dangerous and I
talk about it in the book but we mustn't
throw away the baby with the bath water
we do need a mainstream media for all
the excitement that people like me have
have about New Media and the destruction
of the old way of doing things whatever
that's great but we still do need
mainstream Publications that will spend
a million pounds doing some kind of
genuine investigative journalism we
still do need mainstream institutions I
mean I think the BBC is beyond saving
but the idea of the BBC is actually
quite a good one
um and so on and so forth so yes we
don't have the perfect media landscape
but it's nothing like these
authoritarian countries and again we
shouldn't take that for granted yeah but
so how do you you play that comparison
line then right because like I say it's
a low bar that's my cheap shot at your
argument but in terms of you saying you
know we have a free press notion uh yeah
exactly so by comparison I get it but is
there a more worthwhite How would how
would you deal with people criticizing
the press in this country regardless of
how you do it but I mean by then them
saying actually we are Freer than what's
going on in Russia therefore we should
have the ability to criticize the media
in the west do you know I mean how I
deal with them is usually I call them
idiots on Twitter but
um but
I I don't know how you deal with that
that's just a lack of understanding and
lack of context uh you know we have a
saying in Russia everything is
understood in comparison you cannot
understand the value or meaning of
something unless you have something to
compare it to so
um yes the media in the west has many
issues yes those issues need to be
resolved yes part of the solution to
those issues is New Media attempting to
highlight and expose the problems with
the old media but again we must not
throw the baby out with the bath water
we are fortunate to have a society in
which there is a debate happening most
other societies in the world have no
debate at all it's it's a uniform view
that's imposed from above and so we have
to we have to remember the value of
those institutions try to call them out
when they're going wrong and and
hopefully that is the method by which
they get better fine okay good
um again bear these questions in mind
and other questions that you may have to
develop if you don't like the answer if
you don't like the question we've done a
question just move on if you don't like
the answer uh by all means come back to
it in the question and answer session in
terms of the um education's uh section
you criticize again I'm going to court
you and obviously I'm quoting you out of
context in some regards for the sake of
doing the mainstream media yeah
um it's not a gotcha it's more I just
want to kind of work out what you're
trying you're getting at you criticize
UK education for not teaching about the
ills of socialism you say yeah and you
say that's a good that that's because of
course today's teachers and professors
often think communism is a good idea I
haven't really come across that myself
but anyway but I get the gist
um but does that mean that you are kind
of in favor you know by teaching the
ills of socialism it means that in
Praise of something else by comparative
standards so do you want to have a
politicized education system which no I
just want an objective one I'm quite a
problem automatic like that I just I
think that we we need to teach people
about uh history in a broader context so
if we're talking you know we spend a lot
of time teaching ourselves about the
evils of Nazism quite rightly of course
but if you just compare on a raw
numerical basis communism is far more
dangerous and has taken far more lives
and yet I find that almost nobody in
this country understands that now that
to me seems like quite a big problem and
you say that there you haven't met many
people in Academia who think communism
is a good idea I've met quite a few
number one but also you have to consider
uh what we mean when we're talking about
communism or Marxism I mean many of the
racial conversations we are now having I
mean look at BLM for example right that
is an organization run by people who are
openly Marxist many universities have
professors who are openly Marxist and
many of the identity politics
conversations we have in this country
they're just a new form of Marxism it's
a race-based Marxism instead of of a
class instead of a class-based Marxism
right so except that that undermines the
very notion of what marks is I mean I
would say I'm openly Marxist yeah but I
don't support black lives matter yeah uh
so you know I mean so I just I don't
necessarily recognize the
characterization of this being a
left-wing I mean even I mean socialism
and communism are different uh Marxism
and communism in some respects are
slightly different but so it's kind of
real autism has never been tried
words in my mouth but um but it's that
idea about you know teaching the ills of
socialism was kind of striking phrase
for me I mean if you say the horrors of
Nazism I kind of understand it so are
you saying about teaching you know what
happened under Mars China or haven't got
under you know what happened in the
stalinist Russia yeah but but it's not
just about what happened on the
staliness Russia you've got to
understand the Soviet Union carried on
after Stalin and it wasn't particularly
great after that either and and the
point I think that people don't seem to
have really grasped in the west is the
idea of Communism is evil in and of
itself and it leads to evil outcomes
because it is an evil idea the idea that
you must force people to be equal is
evil whether you're looking at it
through the lens of class or race or sex
or gender or whatever other [ __ ]
people have come up with the idea that
you must put your hand on the lever and
take from people who have drive an
ambition and creativity and whatever
else and you must take from them as much
as possible and give it to people who
have none of those things and who are
not contributing to society that's an
evil idea and we should just be very
clear about and the reason it's evil is
not that it's not a good thing to
redistribute wealth and income from one
group of people to another it's the
amount of tyranny that it takes to
achieve is inevitably going to lead to
millions of people being killed as it
has done every time it's been tried okay
uh I don't recognize that
characterization but uh Fair news
um the um although I recognize stalinist
um purges and also most purchases being
one of the greatest but it's not just
about this is sorry Austin this is what
people don't understand
more people died in Soviet Ukraine alone
from an artificial famine created by the
incompetency of the communist state then
the Nazis killed during the entire
occupation of the Soviet Union right so
it's not just about evil Stalin who came
in and wanted to kill certain people
it's about the fact that a system a
central planning system inevitably
results in this sort of nightmare I
don't know whether it does or not but I
mean advantage of that I mean it did
right I don't know whether you can
necessarily project that but I'm not
sure to defend
Soviet system right I'm certainly not
here to defend the Chinese system we can
have that row again and in China more
people died in the cultural revolution
and in the and in the greatly forward
and even didn't understand yeah so I
mean so we can we can compare statistics
and notes and I'm against both of those
things so don't get me wrong
um but we're we're going off well maybe
wouldn't just
yeah well I'm going to move on now
um so bear that in mind that one up as a
win for me
we'll have that over and just we'll have
that over a bit
um
the um so the early part of the book
um talks about kind of socialist Utopia
um explores hypocrisy um those who
profess to be egalitarian but live the
lives of privilege kind of quite an
interesting uh take you anybody that
hasn't got Michael Moore is all right by
me uh Michael Moore you know talks a
good talk but it has several houses you
say you say then you say Engels had many
factories that Old Chestnut you call the
Bolsheviks grifters that's a good one um
but anyway but but actually you are
known I think for tackling the content
of what people say rather necessarily
their background so uh what is that a
fair line of attack it is a fad line of
attack because uh I am known for
pointing out the hypocrisy of people who
say one thing and do another and I think
people like Bernie Sanders who went on
holiday not just on holiday his
honeymoon was in the Soviet Union right
while people are people from my country
that I come from were starving were
impoverished were struggling to to to
have basic necessities he was there
being given a tour by by people he
thought were just ordinary citizens who
were actually KGB agents whose only job
was to take around gullible westerners
Like Bernie Sanders
um that and then he now is a multi-multi
multi-millionaire who preaches socialism
for everybody it's hypocrisy and it's
complete nonsense I have much more
respect for a Marxist like Cornell West
for example uh who actually lives with
the things that he preaches my issues
with people who are being inconsistent
with the very principles that they
espouse and in the process impoverishing
all those all right uh I won't mention
private schools anyway no just a joke no
no no uh anyway so the next question is
um comedians being targeted it's kind of
interesting that um there's
um there's this kind of stick that
um
comedy or comedians are the last Bastion
of free speeches which is actually quite
interesting isn't it and just take a
look in the last
year two years or so comedians getting
canceled left right and Center
um and it's the idea that um comedians
should be allowed to say things in the
context of a comedy routine which kind
of pushes above pushes the boundary
um so do comedians should comedians have
bigger room for maneuver than say me and
you in this room I mean or maybe put
another way why has it occurred that
comedians seem to be in the Forefront of
actually challenging those kind of very
walk
uh Speech called Boundaries that you
know we're all having to put up with
well the truth is that Austin is most
Community most Comedians and now we're
near challenging the work boundaries of
the modern society they are actually
enforcing them on other comedians uh the
few of us uh people like myself Francis
Andrew Doyle Leo Kirsten I mean I I can
go on for a while in this country who
are doing that uh have all been pushed
out of the mainstream comedy industry
one way or another and have had to
create things outside of that in order
to to even get our voices heard but the
reason that uh that we are at the
Forefront of that is we're constantly we
use irony and satire a lot we say things
that we do not mean uh and in a society
which deliberately misrepresents jokes
as somebody's actual opinion uh
comedians are obviously going to find
themselves in the firing line pretty
quickly
um and of course comedians the other the
job comedians are actually supposed to
have in my opinion is to push back
against the dogma of their day the dogma
of the comedian who the the Dogma that
existed
20 and 30 years ago when I was growing
up my heroes were people like Bill Hicks
and George Carlin and others who were
pushing against the Christian right who
were the ones saying you can't say that
you can't do this you can't whatever
they've been replaced by a religious
left and it's the religious left that is
enforcing its Dogma on everybody at the
moment uh and it's it's and the
comedians who are attempting to
challenge the dogma of the day find
themselves up against that that's why
it's funny you've got people on the
Christian right now defending a
comedian's right to be offensive which
to me is just mind-boggling yeah what
what about
um well let me give you two quotes in
the book which I just wanted to resolve
for me one is where you say more and
more comedians are self-censoring for
economic reasons and promoters are
unlikely to rebook the ACT if they
perceive it to be divisive okay we got
that then you say um the beauty of
capitalism is that consumers assert
their Democratic power with every penny
they spend so you have this kind of
consumer power which you describe the
first Court seems to be kind of cancer
culture that people are canceling you
and not coming to your show not you one
show
um but then the beauty of capitalism
people are allowed to do that is that a
contradiction or is it no there's no
contradiction because the comedy
environment in this country is a
complete uh cabal it's a monopoly run by
a handful of people who decide who gets
which opportunities and if the comedy
industry in this country as it has done
decides that uh the most important thing
about a comedy show is that it's diverse
as opposed to that it's funny uh then
you end up with the comedy shows that
we've ended up with and then what
happens is they get canceled by the
market but first the ideologues who are
booking those shows and making those
shows uh they get to impose their will
on a show like mock the week which
inevitably gets canceled they get to
impose their will on the show like the
mass report which I actually wrote on
for a while which inevitably gets
canceled they get to impose their will
on a show like live at the Apollo which
will soon be canceled because no one
watches it anymore so you've got a
deluded monopolistic cabal that runs the
industry and then you've got the market
which punishes them for the things that
they're doing that don't actually meet
what people want to watch and I always
have to say this because it always
sounds like I'm sort of whining and
complaining I had a great comedy career
I did everything I ever wanted I wrote
for some great uh shows I opened for
some of my heroes on tour I did my own
show in Edinburgh it's all fine you can
still do it it's just that much harder
and because of that a lot of people are
terrified they won't cross any lines and
I can tell you there are hundreds of
comedians in this country who would love
to be able to do the jokes that they
want to do but instead they're going
around doing dick jokes because it's the
only thing that's acceptable anymore
finally then
um which follows on from that I suppose
you say uh towards the end of the book
you say that your status as an immigrant
means that you're protected from the
worst of council culture
um and you describe yourself as Teflon
courted Untouchable immigrant
uh slightly optimistic perhaps well I
look at level Dev I think it didn't work
for him did it but I mean does that does
it mean I mean would that
assume that then you're a bit too
obliging you're too dare I say Tam to be
canceled are you two
um I don't know are you too much engaged
in supporting the Western model uh never
been described as tame before I promise
you it's not equality people usually
associate with me
um no I think the point I'm making about
sort of immigrant privilege if you like
in the context of this conversation is I
don't believe that I would be sitting
here having this conversation with you
if I was a british-born straight white
man that great evil thing uh because the
book would never have been published in
the first place and it wasn't
particularly easy to get it published
anyway
um there people don't know this about
the creative arts and Publishing in this
country in general but
um there's literally like one literary
agent and one publisher that will
publish books like this one and so we
live in a very restricted environment
and the only reason even those
Publishers and even those agents and
even those people are able to work with
someone like me is they can go well guys
guys guys he's not white it's okay
and that to me seems like quite a big
problem
oh there's a Hiatus point there that's
good the inflection through me for a
second okay right ladies and gentlemen
uh I've done me big uh uh so it's over
to you yeah and again it apologies for
my inability to turn it's an age thing
gentleman in the awkward corner
hello um I was just wondering who your
literary influences were in writing the
book uh not to inflate your ego too much
but it reminded me of all well and maybe
even Soldier knitson hmm he's a family
member no no pressure then huh uh can we
take this lady as well
hiya the phenomenon where immigrants the
most patriotic British citizens is not
really a new thing I think it's existed
for decades unlike America where overt
page is more acceptable do you think
there's something in our character that
just quite enjoys negativity
I do uh I do that I also don't I
actually don't know that I agree that
immigrants are the most patriotic I
think they're the ones that are allowed
to be the most patriotic in public I
think that's really the issue I think
there's quite a lot of people in this
country of every background who are very
patriotic about uh Britain uh but they
are concerned about being because you
know being patriotic has been confused
with all sorts of you know xenophobia
races and whatever
um so yeah but in terms of the surgeon
it's in comparison uh and uh oh well uh
I mean those are two people that I have
read so I I don't I I I I feel uh very
British about trying to compare myself
to people that I consider great I I
think uh I actually while I'm a you know
Soldier Nixon's one of the most
formative influences on on my thinking
uh and I quote him in the opening of the
book and I um I I actually tried to
avoid repeating his mistake because the
mistake that he made is when he was
released from the camps uh he was able
to publish
um the gulag archipelago and he was
eventually invited to go to the west and
he went to America where he started
lecturing Americans about what was going
wrong with their society and Americans
don't like that which is why I've come
to Britain where you love being told how
terrible you are all right so I can I
can tell you how to right your wrongs no
so uh yeah those are those are two
people that I respect very much I think
they made very good points and the one
thing I always say to people because
most people haven't read it if you want
to talk if you want to understand the
way that censorship operates
particularly in our society today read
Orwell's preface to Animal Farm where he
talks about how much difficulty he had
in having it published because even in
those days coming back to our
conversation about communism because
uh the Soviets were seen as necessary to
winning World War II it was
it was very very difficult to publish a
book that was critical of that system so
and and it wasn't through hard
censorship it was through enforced
self-censorship and I think he he writes
beautifully about that
uh in terms of very quickly in terms of
the Immigrant stuff I'll follow in
because on the break kind of on the
topic of brexit kind of uh are here to
raise that b word but you say most
people don't hate immigrants they hate
the politicians who say they do because
I think it's a really really important
point and dismissed or misrepresented by
a lot of the media and popular opinion
but it's there to discredit kind of
popular opinion and that idea of
populism uh which is then taken on as we
said before taking on this kind of dark
interpretation populism rather than
being a popular opinion what do you
think about populism the label of
populism because it kind of is brought
in to a lot of conversations these days
which maybe it doesn't deserve to but
also it's given this negative
connotation
well first of all on brexit I voted
remain on that referendum and the thing
that really changed my opinion about
that issue to the extent that I've
changed my opinion about that issue was
I had to watch
the country that I've come to lived in
as a dark-skinned immigrant all my life
be misrepresented as full of you know
half the country's racist half the
country hates immigrants half the
countries blah blah blah blah blah well
first of all that didn't even make any
sense to me because the immigration that
people were concerned about was mainly
from Eastern Europe where people are
white so that doesn't it doesn't ring
true but also my own experience of
living in this country my very valuable
lived experience uh tells me that
there's complete nonsense uh it doesn't
mean to say that populism doesn't exist
people have always wanted to hear a
simplified version of reality that
pandas to all their prejudices and
whatever
um but I just I just think the way we
have the conversation about immigration
is completely insane at the moment uh I
like ice cream I don't want to eat ice
cream for every meal every day for the
rest of my life and attitude to
immigration has got to be the same
immigrants contribute immigrants are
great but when the numbers become it's
sort of like uh my the great man Joseph
Stalin said joke for you um the great
man Joseph Stalin said the quantity has
a quality all of its own and the problem
we have with immigration as a country is
not that immigrants are bad people it's
that when I came to this country in 1995
three percent of the British public
thought that immigration was a major
issue because it wasn't a major issue
right and then you have the Blair era
where more people came into this country
in about 10 years that had come into
this country between
1066 and 1950.
it's quite a big shift and for people to
be concerned about that doesn't make
them racist or xenophobic or whatever
you can be in favor of immigration you
can think that people like me who I
would like to think came to this country
and contributed and have created jobs
for local people and blah blah blah blah
blah
valuable without thinking that open
borders is a great idea it's it's not
that and as I as you know I talk about
this in a book quite a lot
left-wing politicians let alone
right-wing politicians have been making
the very point that I've just made for
the last 30 years Barack Obama was to
the right of Donald Trump on immigration
it's just everyone forgot
yeah well it was Barack Obama who
maintained the wall uh from America to
Mexico didn't he but um and the whole
issue which I presumably discussing in
the last session on Ukraine about
sovereignty and about borders it's kind
of fundamentally in our face in our face
now so it's something which maybe those
remainers who
denied its existence maybe have to
rethink uh anyway any more for any more
there's a gentleman at the very back
oh there's lots of all right sorry I
didn't
because you're wearing t-shirts I just
assumed you were like saluting or
something uh take this gentleman and
then we'll go back to the T-shirt what
kind of session do you think this is
well I'm pandering to your Putin desk uh
agenda
brilliant thank you Constantine um you
spoke about wanting to have a more
objective education system what role
then do you think parents should play in
helping to shape the national curriculum
and the content that their children are
learning is a very timely topical issue
both in the UK and overseas I think
there are discussions about it at the
Battle of ideas and I asked because
obviously every parent will have their
own subjective opinion about what should
and shouldn't be taught how does society
manage that yeah it's an interesting
question and very much above my pay
grade but what I would say about it is
uh I for the first few years of my life
so from until I was about 13 I obviously
was educated in the Soviet education
system which was very good on the hard
science as the chemistry that whatever
but also contained a huge amount of
historical and cultural indoctrination
which everybody knew was complete
[ __ ] and so the role of the parent
in my opinion partly will be about you
know what the curriculum should be or
whatever but actually everything begins
in the home you have to give your
children the context for the things that
they're being taught you have to
inoculate them against some of the crap
that they're going to be inevitably
taught in any school and you know when I
talk about a more objective system I
just I think we are failing to educate
our children and I this is true for my
generation too and by the way you know
when I went to school in this country it
coincided with like a five-year period
of my life where my family had money so
they sent me to a good school for a very
short time before going bankrupt again
and blah blah blah but uh I went to a
good school and we were taught history
terribly
terribly I learned more in history by
watching a one-hour YouTube video than I
learned in my entire time at school
right so I I don't know that that this
gets fixed necessarily in the education
system and I think the challenging with
the challenges we're seeing is the
result of the sexual Revolution and the
breakdown of the family are much more
where these issues are happening where
there's not enough parents to basically
teach their children right from wrong
the the the the stuff that they're being
taught in school that is completely
nonsensical versus what's actually true
and to set a context for the things so
uh as as a new parent this is probably
extreme optimism on my part but I'm sort
of hopeful that I can teach my children
the stuff that they need to know and
protect them from some of the
indoctrination they're going to get in
school
very good all right take these two
gentlemen statue-esque figures oh yeah
uh I think a lot of the problems we have
in politics in the west come from the
fact that a lot of a lot of people think
that everyone else in the world thinks
exactly like us
so you know people don't understand why
Putin would invade Ukraine people don't
understand why someone would vote for
brexit or just disagree with them on
something
do you see us recovering from that any
any way of of stepping into other
people's shoes and understanding that
they have different motives and morals
and values and and and they're gonna
they're gonna act on those and and that
drives their behavior
I'll take the other guy thank you sir as
well yeah uh two very quick things uh a
personal question um what are you most
what are you most proud of in the past
year the baby the book or America and
the second thing very quickly is um
do you think the whole culture war is
because everybody's bored and we've got
nothing to believe in I.E lack of
religion would there be a culture or if
we actually had things to really believe
in and we weren't so comfortable
um yeah both good questions uh so the
first question is just remind me briefly
because my memory is failing people
people believe that everyone else across
the world yeah yeah how can we get
people to listen to each other and
understand each other's point of view
yeah well this is one of the paradoxes
of the progressive leftist way of
thinking because it's all about
inclusion and tolerance and
understanding and empathy yet they are
the very people who don't seem to
understand that the reason people have
different points of view is different
genetics different upbringings different
life experience different lived
experience different all of these things
right and that I think is a large
largely a product of social media
whereas I say certain types of ideas get
way more traction because they sound
better even though often they're
completely wrong so I think we will get
away from that way of doing business
whenever we find a way to destroy social
media uh it's probably the only way how
many subscribers do you have yeah let's
hold on to them social media
um and what am I most proud of well I
didn't really have that much to do with
the baby I I can tell you it's a very
limited level of involvement
um no I I you know what the thing I am
most proud of actually is the
trigonometry is now a small business
that employs
uh including me Francis and our producer
Anton another seven or eight people now
uh about seven or eight people and I'm
I'm really proud of that I'm really
proud that we employ people that we give
people meaningful work that people come
and work for us for very little money
let's be honest because they love what
they do because they love being involved
in a project that is passionate where
we're all pulling in the same direction
and uh you know Francis and I have been
we've transformed from basically two
idiot comedians to actually managing a
small team of people and looking after
people and making sure that they're
developing what they're doing to me that
is really the most exciting thing
yeah yeah
[Music]
um yeah so I'm excited about that but in
terms of the culture was are we just
bored I think you're right that a lot of
the problems we have in the west are a
function of our comfort and prosperity
um and every time something goes badly
wrong I am really hopeful that that is
the kick that we need which is like when
the pandemic happens you remember there
was that like brief moment when
everybody was like oh guys we're a
society we should pull in the same
direction let's bring some food to our
neighbor right and then we had George
Floyd and everybody you know everybody
went mentioned that we need we need to
do what
we need to look after people and we need
to have solidarity with ourselves and
whatever and just there was a couple of
months that that everything was kind of
going I was like oh wow we're starting
to unite around this Common Thread that
we face and then you have Dominic
Cummings uh who as Francis always points
out must have been the biggest supporter
of BLM because it just took all the
attention away from him and that happens
and the world goes crazy I mean you see
people posting these videos now from uh
the summer of 2020 where you've got like
white people kneeling to black people
right and I was saying at the time what
this is mental this is completely mental
my first day unit Goldsmith a year ago I
had white girls coming to me I'm so
sorry for being white
how nice for you my friend
actually there's a terrific uh have you
seen this viral video by Russian uh by
the Russian States yes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
laughs IES
[Music]
[Music]
bye
what do you want watching I want to go
to the toilets is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
free
um
[Music]
it's really clever well that's the thing
it really isn't that clever it's
actually very easy to satirize if you
can put it on television which you can't
yeah in this country it trust me I can
rustle up some comedy writers that could
do that a hundred times better he just
wouldn't go anywhere
I thought it was quite funny you know
I'm not saying it's not funny it was
great
in relation to your views on the
mainstream media being someone who works
with an amazed media but not in this
country
um what do you how do you think oh
what's your opinion of the media
coverage of the war I mean it's a big
question but what are the strengths and
weaknesses in your opinion of how the
war is being covered in the industry
it's a good question you've you've
obviously caught me in a massive
generalization because the mainstream
media is composed of all sorts of
different outlets and different people
will cover it differently
um if I think if I think of Courage of
the war and the mainstream media I sort
of think of the BBC
and I think the BBC has
not been inaccurate generally speaking
while also
the main issue I have is I don't think
that you could possibly work out why the
war is happening
why Russia invaded what's actually going
on on the ground and what is likely to
be the future and what are the most
important issues from the BBC because
all you see is pretty Refugee running
away from bombs or you know uh the lgbtq
survivors of Putin's invasion in
Rotherham being integrated with a family
these are all great stories I just don't
think that they really educate people
about some of the issues and I think
it's one of the reasons that the
alternative media has been so involved
in covering this issue and attempting to
bring certain issues into life because I
just don't think the mainstream media is
calibrated to educate people and to give
them the information that they need
because they're much more you know it's
odd to me because
I sort of used to think that it's the
online space where everything's
clickbait but actually I often feel now
with the mainstream media they are the
ones that are doing most of the
clickbait uh because they're going you
know if it bleeds it leads type of thing
and we all get look I have family in
Russia and Ukraine who've all been
affected by all of this and it's
terrible I just don't know how much yet
another story about the poor victims of
war advances people's understanding of
what's happening and that has always
been my priority to try and explain to
people why it's happening why does it
matter to the west and I think people
really don't understand uh you know uh
it's funny I wrote this um
thread on Twitter recently which was a
translation of Vladimir Putin's latest
speech that some of you probably have
read
and I had a bunch of mainstream
journalists follow me afterwards and ask
me questions and these are people who
cover the war I'm like why are you
asking a satirist and podcaster what
Vladimir Putin is saying how come you
haven't got a whole team of people
analyzing your speeches breaking it down
explaining to people in the west what
he's actually saying it's a catastrophic
failure and it's important because if we
in the west don't understand what's
going on how the hell are we going to
react her in the right way
so why haven't they uh I look you
probably know more about it than me I am
just seeing the symptoms I can't explain
what the disease is exactly uh I think
there's probably not a lot of money in
in doing a three-hour breakdown of of
what's happening in Ukraine and there's
probably quite a lot of Clicks in people
who want to just see a pretty Refugee
running away from a bomb
the theory okay uh going behind you as
well
we'll take the white guy first as this
is right um just so on the history of
trigonometry there's a a great episode
where constant and Francis talked for
about an hour and a half about the story
from being in a flattened Allston to the
Empire they are now and it's very it's
quite life-affirming partly because it's
been through so much kind of [ __ ] for
the better term uh and kind of come out
the other side although Anton doesn't
come out of it very well
um but you know I guess he's the butt of
the joke often
um but no I wanted to pick up an
appointment you made in the plenary
about Ukraine earlier on and a point
that someone else made earlier about how
other people see Western values and
someone asked about how we uh try and
really encourage people to see them in a
more uh positive way but could you give
some examples of how in
Soviet Russia and also imposed Soviet
Russia something that we would take for
granted or at least maybe the people in
this room would like liberal democracy
or equality or tolerance of speech and
so on would be seen by the authorities
or the the people who shape uh public
opinion and the culture what were we
really surprised to hear would be a
common view in Russia well Russia has
never had a single democratic transition
of power ever
ever
the first mention of Russia is 882
that's the key of Andreas that people
talk about in its entire history Russia
has never had a single democratic
transition of power right so that seems
to me quite important
um that's something we completely don't
understand and it's true of most of the
World by the way
it's true of most of the other countries
in the world democracy is a quite rare
quite unique and quite a fragile thing
which is why it has to be guarded so
carefully
um the the idea that in the Soviet Union
you would express your opinion in public
and
that opinion was unpopular and you would
be safe was no it would never occur to
anyone that such a ridiculous thing
Could Happen uh in the late 80s this is
why we were having the argument only
about stalinism my grandfather this is
what one of the things I talk about in
the book he criticized the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan much like people
are now in Russia criticizing the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and he was
immediately fired from his job his wife
was fired from her job their children
that's my father and my aunt were kicked
out of University
for one comment that he made in private
and there are people in Russia Today who
initially when The Invasion happened
they went out with placards to protest
and the placards would say for peace and
they would get instantly arrested and
dragged away into prison so then they
started going out with no placard at all
just standing with their hands in there
and they would get arrested
the idea that you should be able to
protest against your government because
you disagree with it
but it doesn't really occur to most
people everywhere and the only way that
they are able to do so is to go out and
get their head smashed in by the riot
police as you see in Russia as you are
now seeing in Iran as you would see as
you saw in China of course it was
Tiananmen Square and not just Tiananmen
Square but it was a well it is a
Country-Wide thing what happened
um people in the west absolutely do not
realize how rare and unique and precious
what we have here is and to the point
where it wouldn't even occur to people
in other countries that these things are
good things to have because they've
never had them
yeah it's funny because when I I taught
in China for about six years and uh when
I first took my Chinese students out and
I offered to buy them a drink mainly
because it was 25 Pence for a plane but
uh probably more drink and then one girl
said uh I don't drink in public
okay so you know you think okay what the
hell does that mean yeah I don't drink
so I kind of harangued sufficiently that
she explained that in in the 70s the
family always used to have their meals
outside in the in the village and then
the grandfather got drunk and said too
much and before you know it he was
hauled off her father was hold off so
there's a family rule not to drink in
public you know and it's like moments
like that when I mean you've lived it
right but almost like that when you
realize this is a different system and a
different perception about you know what
your personal and private versus public
experiences so I think it's kind of very
useful to to remember that these are
very very different social systems and
kind of very difficult as somebody was
asking at the back there very difficult
to grasp the kind of the conception of
what it what what China mindset might be
at all that doesn't not meant to be
racist I suppose it's generally
difficult to understand how they think
about certain things and interpret them
because it's of such a different
historical magnitude of what we've had
in in the west so it's going to very
important point you raise hey Francis do
you like locals I live in London Mike so
obviously not the only pleasure I get
from the locals is when we share an
intimate moment as we watch a Japanese
tourists get trapped in a tube door
but I wasn't talking about their locals
I was talking about our community on
locals you mean the one where you get
phenomenal behind the scenes content
when you thank you
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew door's
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
take the gentleman further away please
okay so just um you said you had cast
iron
um immigrant privilege B before I'm just
wondering how much longer that will last
given
um that the uh in general the left have
now discovered from the last two
cabinets that you know black and Asian
people can be toys too and in some cases
significant significantly more
right-wing than the um van van
cabinet colleagues and also in in
America there are more Hispanic people
who voted for for Trump so it's a
narrative of the Gammon or white
privilege is that going to hold forever
or will they have to come up with some
kind of new kind of formulation about
who the problematic people are yeah like
crazy I use superficially in immigrant
yeah well I don't know I'm I'm
internally xenophobic I guess
um no I I think it's it's funny isn't it
because anyone with half a brain knows
that immigrant communities actually tend
to be more conservative on particularly
on social issues than the native
population uh yeah we pretend that
ethnic minorities are the sort of
monolith who all believe you know in
Eternal progress or whatever it is
um I I don't know how that issue is
going to play out I mean uh I don't know
how people in this room feel I don't
know how people in the country feel I uh
I I think many of these ideas you know
the idea that a black Cabinet member of
a conservative government which is
frankly useless at the moment but
nonetheless a a black Cabinet member of
that government has internalized racism
because they have the wrong opinion
According to some white leftist that
seems to me to be slightly discredited
by now
um and so I don't really I think
increasingly people take less notice of
it I think the way that we are having
this conversation in this room is
probably not the way it might have been
had two years ago I think we're all
starting to kind of
to realize the to borrow one of the
language tricks we're starting to
realize the gas lighting that's been
happening and I think more and more
people will open their eyes to how much
crap they've been sold about it and I
think you're just particularly as the as
the makeup of our society changes as we
see that politics increasingly reflects
every ethnicity in this country
increasingly reflects every variety of
person whatever I think that issue will
probably go away because people like me
and people like you and others just we
we're kind of immune to this like if I
mean someone once called me a nazia or
Jewish naughty the best kind like it's
it gets silly after a while you know
what I mean
okay uh this gentleman all right
um sorry for Blackpool and uh if if we
don't if you're oppressed well yes I
mean I'm probably a thick basis
northerner northerner nobody's ever
really called me out I worked for BBC so
I can't really say much on on social
medias about politics I'm not allowed to
have a view
um and obviously the BBC is run by a guy
that used to Market fizzy drinks to fat
kids so
um you know and Bill Hicks his viewers
on marketeers you you I'm sure will
remember
um for this question you wrote an
immigrant's letter to the West have you
had a letter back
an actual letter or a direct response
back from an individual and what was it
what was the best one
it was Douglas Murray's a very generous
review in which he he sort of he he
thanked me for writing the book and he
said that
um the the feeling is reciprocated and
he spoke on behalf of the West which was
in Douglas's style and who I love but um
but yeah that was you know
um right or left or whatever I think
Douglas Murray is one of the most
insightful
public commentators that this country's
producing in quite some time uh I don't
agree with Douglas on everything I agree
with him on a lot of things that he says
I think he's had the courage to address
a number of issues that nobody wanted to
be honest about way ahead of time and so
when he wrote a a review suggesting that
you know he was grateful to me for
writing the book uh you know that meant
a lot to me yeah
any hostile ones the reviews yeah no no
not reviews but the letter the concept
that you've written this book and oh
yeah oh it was funny there was a woman
on Twitter who followed me after I
translated that Putin speech and she was
so enthusiastic about everything that
I'd said about as you absolutely
brilliant can't wait to read your book
next day she she just like sent me a
hundred like hate-filled messages about
how wrong and bad and terrible my book
is uh so there was a I I managed to
persuade one person very quickly yeah
very good very good Toby I run a kind of
alt media website called
um The Daily skeptic was lockdown
Skeptics and we've had a number of
problems with censorship so I think
Facebook have currently banned the daily
skeptic Facebook account
um we were closed by
um PayPal um about a month ago they
eventually changed their minds but for
and it looked as though they did that
because they thought we were guilty of
spreading misinformation about the
covid-19 vaccines
um and I wondered I know I know
trigonometry has in the past had some
similar Problems YouTube videos being
removed you convinced that you're being
Shadow banned not convinced we have
direct deputies but we have evidence
I wondered um as as trigonometry has
grown grown its audience as it's become
a a business with seven people whose
livelihoods you're partly now
responsible for has your how how do you
now navigate this world do you do you
find yourself having to self-censor more
and more to avoid this kind of
um actual censorship by big Tech uh no
because I firmly believe and Francis and
I think our whole team is United and
believing that the point of trigonometry
is to explore difficult issues and I
think the moment we start doing that I
don't think the people in this room
would be in this room so we we cannot
sell out to that
um and if the if the day comes that we
can no longer do what we do on YouTube
then we will find another way of doing
it and if that means that we all have to
take a hit we've always been very clear
every time we talk with you know myself
Francis and Anton about you know well
maybe we should like give this person a
bit more salary or give ourselves a bit
more salary so we can do whatever
we that's always with the understanding
that you know things may go up as well
as down because of the nature of what we
do uh what I am very concerned about
Toby as you you know you and I have
spoken this about this before and you've
had some issues with PayPal recently is
that like if you've got the wrong
opinion you can't have a bank account
which is the direction we're going that
is a very very dark path that is a very
dark path and uh that's got to I mean
we've got to fight so hard against that
because you know before you know it
you're not gonna have electricity if
you've got the wrong opinion I just
think
I think that that is the the most scary
thing to me uh and uh I I wish more
people would focus their attention on
that
can I just jump in
um the PayPal issue I've just canceled
my PayPal accounts precisely because of
your um problems but what do you think
because I'm I'm opposed to Consumer
boycotts so I had a bit of an ethical
turmoil as to whether I should be doing
this uh in support of you or whether I
should actually be not endorsing the
idea that I can bring my consumer power
to to play on distorting uh a company's
um own decision-making processes how do
you sit on sorry how do you sit on this
well thank you for for closing your
PayPal account I think lots of people
did it's not all in it but anyway well
but I think I think the number of people
who did may have contributed to their
decision to restore the three accounts
of mine that they closed
um I think that um you often hear
a slightly different argument to the one
you made which is that well why should
we Fetter the freedom of Association of
these private companies by saying they
can't discriminate against certain
customers on the basis of their
political beliefs
um uh you know you can always you can
always go with another payment processor
that isn't going to discriminate in that
way and the market will solve the
problem and I think there are two
arguments against that the first is that
well first of all
um PayPal is a monopoly um it's about
eight times larger than its nearest
competitor and it's quite difficult to
make a success of sites like
trigonometry and the daily skeptic which
depend on donations amongst other things
if PayPal closes your account
um the second thing is I think you know
it's odd you hear people on the left
like James O'Brien making this kind of
libertarian argument as though they'd
suddenly joined the Institute of
economic Affairs
um you know he says why shouldn't they
discriminate against you they're a free
company this is a free Society but you
wouldn't say the same thing if they
discriminated against someone on the
basis of the color of their skin or
their religion or their sexual
orientation and I think your political
belief should be in the same category
and you know to your point uh
Constantine I think we definitely do
need to do something about this urgently
to prevent the emergence of a
chinese-style social credit system in
the west except you know without
communist authorities enforcing
ideological Orthodox it's these
capitalist corporations in California
what can we do about it well the Free
Speech Union is lobbying the government
to amend a bill currently going through
Parliament to make it more difficult for
companies like PayPal and lots of other
financial services companies to
discriminate against people on the basis
of their political beliefs like whether
we'll make any Headway I don't know but
we're certainly hoping to do that yeah
and and everyone should know I we are
trigonometry are huge fans of the Free
Speech Union I think it's really
important um and you do great work can I
just add one other thing as well uh
coming back to your question about you
know self-censoring to protect our staff
or whatever the one principle the
guiding principle of my life and I'm
fortunate to be able to have this
principle because we live in a Time
where people like you and I are not
burnt under stake
um is that the truth of it is that in
our society I think if you make a
stand-on principle that cost you in the
short term
it probably will benefit you in the long
term at least that is the belief that I
operate by I'm sure at some point it
will turn out to be untrue but generally
my the way I try to carry myself in the
in the world is based on that idea which
is that if you stand up for what's right
now you may suffer the consequences
early but in the long run you will be
Vindicated and actually shown to be
correct and that will reinforce people's
support for you
um you will find an audience of people
who believe in what you do that you know
I know you did a lot of
opposing of the government's
restrictions around lockdown which was a
big concern of mine as well and I was
frankly you know sending quite rude
messages to government ministers and
whatever who now say to me oh you were
sort of right do you know what I mean
and so I think that
standing up for what you truly know to
be the right thing even when it's
difficult will benefit you in the long
run and so from that perspective if at
some point it comes to that we are
starting to have trouble with our
payment system or whatever
we will find a way uh and I I hope that
people if more people had that attitude
I think we'd be making more progress
faster and I do think in the modern
world it is genuinely true particularly
because you know you with the Free
Speech Union are able to look after the
the little man who maybe doesn't have a
big platform and doesn't want to build a
big platform they just wanted to make a
joke at work or whatever you know what I
mean uh so yeah I think what you're
doing is very important very good lovely
love in there mutual appreciation
society
yes and good we'll take this last here
please
lady sorry my question is following on
um from self-counseling and um it's
going to be just touching on the c word
not capitalism comedy I see comedy as a
high level of intelligence and I'm
wondering how can we sustain it as um
being an outlet
um basically walk in that fine line
between being offensive to some and not
offensive to others um through Council
culture
how can we sustain is it through
perseverance
look there's a couple of answers I mean
the flip announcers comedians need to
grow some balls I suppose but
um the the bigger answer is I think the
internet is the answer and that's why
I'm so opposed to the online harms bill
and the online whatever it's called now
they keep changing the name but the the
in my view the biggest issue that we
face I feel weird sort of answering a
question and with my back to you but
um the biggest challenge from my
perspective and the thing that I am most
focused on is
we spent four and a half years on
trigonometry pointing out
the hypocrisy of this Wok IDC and also
challenging some of the anti-worker do
you see that is also now starting to
emerge right and that is good for as
long as that was happening the problem
that we have is
if you don't have a positive vision of a
Counter Culture people aren't going to
buy into it right and so I think what we
have to start to do is to shape a
positive vision of The Counter Culture
whether it's comedy whether it's
anything else and people just have to go
out and do stuff they gotta go out and
create the internet allows you to find
your audience so from a comedy
perspective that's part of it and then
here's the new dad part of me which is
you know I think this
doomsday narrative that exists on the
left particularly to do with
environmentalism and on the right
there's a sort of it's not maybe equal
but there's a similar sort of you know
the West is all decadent and degraded
and devoid of any values so you know
let's let Vladimir Putin take over he's
a good Christian of whatever whatever
nonsense these people have bought it
bought into but there's a sort of like
you know the world's over type of
narrative and that is just nonsense and
people need to have more kids not fewer
more kids of the solution uh instead of
being the problem uh so that's got to be
a big part of it and then we just have
to take an honest appraisal on
culturally about environmentalism and we
have to be honest we have to say look
the climate is changing human beings
contribute to it the world's not going
to end in 10 years and if we poured all
the energy that we pour onto paintings
into actually working on problems and
solving problems technologically we'd be
a lot better off and by the way we
wouldn't be buying our energy from our
enemies making ourselves vulnerable
making ourselves unable to respond
strongly like we've seen so that
positive Counter Culture is forming I'm
having all sorts of conversations with
all sorts of people it's sort of behind
closed doors at the moment but believe
me there's The Counter Culture building
comedians are going to be a big part of
that Sato is going to be a bit part of
that movies are going to be a big part
of that because if you look at the
output from Hollywood and and wherever
over the last decade I mean I used to
love the cinema I don't go I haven't
been to the cinema for God knows how
long because it's all crap right and uh
that the demand is there the market will
fulfill it as long as we're still
allowed to do stuff on the internet
the market will decide uh gentlemen on
the last there
hi um at the moment we've got a
conservative government whose support
for free speech and for anti-work issues
is positive but at best feeble uh we've
got the prospect of a labor government
very very strongly coming in a couple of
years do you think we're all going to be
swimming in water of a different
temperature then okay the LED in front
um well you mentioned that there is a
Marxist problem in education and as a
student I wholeheartedly agree I feel
like whenever I do a history essay the
professors they want you to write about
history in a certain way I remember in
my second year I did a module on the
Soviet Union and the professors just
kept talking they kept saying that the
Western historians were essentially they
saw so many negatives in a Soviet Union
and so we were
they advise against you know using their
arguments and isas and I remember
um a friend of mine she's she's half
Ukrainian and she felt she personally
felt really uncomfortable
um in her lessons because these um
professors that you know they've never
lived in a Soviet Union before they just
kept saying oh you know it wasn't there
were some things that weren't great but
you know there are other things that we
can still praise and you know clearly
the Soviet Union was just you know
generally a you know a bad a bad thing
um how do we solve this issue of you
know
the Marxist problem in education
thank you uh I don't know that you can
solve the Marxist I'll come back to the
gentleman's question I don't know that
you cancel I mean academics are always
going to lean in that direction because
they like ideas that don't work but
sound good
um this is what they do uh and uh this
is some um I can't remember it's Melissa
Chen I don't know if you guys Melissa
Chen uh I'm a big fan of uh she tweeted
something a long time ago she said you
cannot remain woke
when you're building anything whether
that's muscle whether that's a business
whether that's anything right so the
moment you get in the Practical real
world
you start to be confronted by the
reality that people are not equal
they're not born with equal intelligence
or equal drive or equal passion or
anything and so the people who live in
the in the towers of Academia they're
always going to be slightly deluded and
I think the way that that gets solved is
the way you're solving it which is
critical thinking uh you are there
you're being asked these to do these
assignments you're starting to see the
flaws and arguments that are being
presented to you and I don't imagine
you're going to come out of that
experience being a Marxist so that we
kind of solve that problem this is only
in your case
um and I think eventually over time uh
people will grow out of it the I don't I
mean Academia is important but I think
culture is much more important and I
think that is really you know the
conversation I was the point I was
making to the lady there is if we can
change the culture everything else will
go with it uh and uh they're always
going to be Marxist professors
um you know that's just what they do but
so on your point about the conservative
government I mean I have some
conservative friends who would say this
isn't really a particularly conservative
government and uh I mean they're
probably probably less woke than Kia
stalma's party might be but they're
still pushing through the Online safety
build which is as Andrew Doyle will tell
you filled with critical social justice
language and ideology from start to
finish and is in my opinion if not
purposely built then certainly
accidentally built precisely to suppress
the sort of Counter Culture emerging
that I'm talking about where people are
free to make jokes on the internet free
to speak for you to take risks Etc so uh
but yeah I mean the only thing that
could possibly be worse than the current
shambles is a labor government which
we're almost certainly going to get
yeah so it's Happy Days Ahead mate yeah
and on a high yeah uh there's a few more
but if you always say anything just in
terms of what that lady was saying there
because it's interesting the
the way you phrased it um I mean part of
it I agree with and part of it I'm just
a little bit kind of worried about when
you say Ukrainian student was worried it
sounded like she was being triggered by
somebody saying that you know what was
going on in the Ukraine was you know the
fault of the ukrainians or whatever it
was uh and there's a in soas you know
School of Oriental and African studies
uh their Student Union about two years
ago did a big takeover uh argument that
how dare you know white Western expert
professors or just call them professors
um who had spent all their years
understanding Africa uh how dare they
teach African students because you know
what do they know you know they haven't
had the lived experience and they
basically are imposing a kind of a
western-centric understanding of Africa
on students rather than maybe a
knowledgeable one I can't speak to the I
think that's the opposite of the point
no I don't think I don't think it was I
think the fact is that there was an
element of that in the question right
but obviously more broadly than that she
was talking about the fact that there's
a you know a Marxist
um you know uh
um tone to what some of the students
lecturers are teaching them so I think
I'm just slightly worried about the
middle ground of what was being said
there I mean I don't think that the
teachers you know have to be
Russian or from the Soviet Union to have
an opinion
um
on savior history is just that they were
kind of being insensitive I mean it's
like
you just can't you just can't ignore
certain things that happened in the
Soviet Union you can't just brush away
just because the dominant historiography
in the west is that you know it was it
was bad and we just want to disagree
with what the West says because you know
we're working stuff I mean for example
um
I have a teacher a professor who is very
knowledgeable
um about the country my family is from
and you know and he's white and I don't
disagree like I don't think it's a bad
thing that he's not about where I'm from
because he's why I'm just saying that
you can't just you know forget that some
things happen in history that are wrong
basically well I actually speak to this
very point in the book uh uh I don't
know if you've you've read it but I talk
about in one of the chapters why the
Soviet Union was brilliant
I list all the reasons it was generally
brilliant free education free health
care uh free child care uh you know very
high standard of education on the hard
Sciences
uh equality for all uh much less wealthy
and income inequality that we have in
this country and as I say in the book
it's a pity you had to kill 50 million
people to make it happen
um that's kind of the trade-offs right
and I think the point that you're making
is is very valid one which is you've got
people who are essentially saying you
should disregard a particular way of
looking at this issue because it's all
Western which seems to me actually is
the exact opposite of of the argument
that's just been made so I I agree with
you completely what it is picking up
when I was picking up on the point of
her friend yeah who was upset by what
this lecture was saying very minor point
in the entire equation yeah so I'm not
I'm not gonna go at you but what I'm
saying is I think I would also be quite
upset I mean I would I would demonstrate
differently yeah because I'm making sure
an [ __ ] but if I was in a in in that
classroom I'd be going you have no idea
what you're talking about this is what
happened this is what my family went
through it's called fighting back
arguing the case exactly right that
wasn't the point of me you sir
um so the I think the biggest uh problem
that we're all facing and why a lot of
people like ours like the sleeping
Giants are waking up is what's happened
and I'm old enough to remember since the
70s is this is this creep of postmodern
Marxism in the uh Elites and the
universe you're triggering Austin here
yeah yeah it's it's of course modern
Marxism you can have a girl well it's a
combination of Jordan Peterson I made a
good point about it
um and what's happened is especially in
the humanities but it's now creeping
into apparently math now is also
um a white supremacy
um that's another thing
um look it up
um and what's happened is that all the
people who are educated in the
humanities go into the media and go into
all these big corporations and into
government
and it's it's an infection that runs
deep in all the most powerful Elites uh
in society and all the big organs
of communication and the difficulties
we're having
uh whether it's PayPal or Facebook or
Twitter is is simply because
there is a
there's a shouty elite
backed up by Greta sunberg and others
um who who get the oxygen of publicity
and the Monopoly on the on the public
debate and so that's the big Challenge
and what we really need is a is a proper
alternative Marketplace which is your is
what you're doing in your own way but it
needs to get bigger
there needs to be an alternative to
PayPal but the problem is as someone has
saved these these guys are monopolies
uh they're not they're not capitalists
at all they're they are they are
corporate monopolies they're
anti-capitalists you know capitalism is
all about being able to get you know you
vote with your feet if you don't think
this works uh move somewhere else and we
need we need a leakage where we can get
out and challenge it okay great thank
you very much you madam and yourself
yeah hi um I just um wanted to say I
really liked your sub stack article
about how to destroy a progressive
argument three steps to do it
um one you know where is the evidence to
on what grounds I can't remember the
other these are not mine by the way I
should say I don't want to take credit
for Thomas Soules workers uh yeah those
are these are Thomas Soul's three
questions compared to what at what cost
and what hard evidence do you have hard
evidence yeah
and as I especially liked your point in
terms of how the one of the Logics to
Progressive is um you know abolishing
prisons if you just presume everyone has
a good nature and people only commit
crimes because they're failed by the
system rather than just simply being bad
people
and I guess I want to task
you know what
are we seeing any dangers at the moment
of the excesses of progressivism Beyond
you know theoretical posturing in
Academia
well look look sorry it's interrupt but
it's a good really good question so for
we'll talk about Thomas soul in a second
because it's really important but if you
look at what's happening in places like
California where we just came back from
in terms of releasing criminals from
prison in terms of not arresting people
if they're stealing stuff from a shop
that's worth less than 900 if you're not
arresting people who are sleeping on the
street and you're not actually giving
them the support they need because most
of them are drug addicts and have mental
health issues that they need treatment
for
um then yes you create a progressive
hellhole that productive people move out
of as has happened with California so of
course you see that
um but the really interesting
philosophical point that you pick up on
is that I mean I don't know how many
people here familiar with Thomas Soul
the American Economist and and many
other things absolutely one of my
favorite thinkers and um he wrote many
many very interesting books but one of
them is called the conflict of Visions
in which he talks about the two visions
of the world that people have and one of
them is what he calls the constrained
Vision which is the idea that human
beings are fallible they are flawed they
are imperfect and the very best way to
understand how human beings are likely
to behave in the future is to look at
their behavior in the past so if you
look at human behavior in the past you
would not be surprised when Russia
invades Ukraine because people have been
going to war for the entire time the
human beings have existed
and in every other area you you accept
that people will commit acts of murder
and heinous crimes and it's not because
they've been quote unquote failed by the
system but because Society produces a
certain number of people who will commit
crimes you've given the opportunity and
motive and whatever
the unconstrained Vision however is the
vision of the ability to perfect
humankind uh the idea that that all the
great revolutionaries whether it's the
French Revolution or the Russian
Revolution underpinned all of that which
is we can transform Humanity we can make
a new man homo soveticus is what he was
called in the Soviet Union who can be
reprogrammed away from crime away from
having more allegiance to his family
than to Communism or whatever and it is
this ideology this Progressive ideology
that is at the root of a lot of things
including the fact that we didn't really
plan how we would deal with Russia in
this sort of situation because what I'm
saying is I mean it's as old as time the
Romans knew this serious patchum
Parabellum if you want peace prepare for
war because war is always coming and it
is only people who are strong who are
able to resist and prevent War by
showing strength in advance of the war
right so there are all sorts of areas
where this
is very optimistic but inaccurate way of
thinking is damaging our societies
internally but also geopolitically and
and it's a big problem
find a water
so congratulations on the baby thank you
and this is a good segue for the
question so what would be your advice to
Second Generation immigrants suffering
from an identity crisis like me so for
example I was born in this city but my
face is from Egypt uh at school a small
minority used to call me a terrorists
fast forward three decades later on
Muhammad Salah so so this is I think
it's a key question that there's a
identity crisis especially if it's top
down it seems to be we're destroying our
values and if there's nothing that pulls
us together then what is your advice
yeah it's a really good question
actually a really good one uh to finish
on I don't know exactly what you mean
because identity crisis is two words and
what you're personally experiencing I
don't know uh I think uh in terms of you
know being bullied at school and all
that sort of thing the the valuable
thing that my parents always taught me
and it's it's very uh bigoted and
Prejudiced but they always said look
there's a bell curve of IQ in society
some people are idiots and the people
who are being racist to you are probably
idiots so you probably should just
ignore them right yeah of course right
and they're they're one of the tales of
the of the bell curve right
um uh so that's what I would deal with
but in terms of your identity now I
would say to you what do you believe do
you believe in Western values do you
believe in British rallies do you
believe in democracy do you believe
Freedom do you believe in the right of
people to speak their mind even if it
offends you or others uh and if you do
then you are as British as anybody
you've come to this country or your
parents uh came to this country and you
grew up here uh you're as British as
anybody make yourself British contribute
to the society I don't know what you do
for a living or what you're going to do
for a living but for me you know when um
Brian asked me about what I'm most proud
of like I said I'm most proud that I I
contribute to the society that I've
built something here that other people
benefit from and if you do that uh I
don't think you need to have an identity
crisis your face is not from Egypt your
face is from wherever your face is you
know your genetics are what they are
doesn't make you anything other than
genetics people can live in different
parts so you you've got a point you want
to make
the values that are in your book yeah
try not uphold the values that in your
book yeah but if it's all crumbling
around me yeah then there's nothing for
me to hold on to I understand Egyptian
yeah living in the UK yeah yeah and this
is the Doomsday narrative that I've been
talking about and my book is full of
warnings and predictions about things
going wrong if we don't but I believe
it's people like you and it's people
like me and it's like everybody else in
this room that if we believe that these
things are worth defending and we
actually defend them then they will not
crumble that's why I wrote the book and
I think that's why you ask the question
because you don't want these things to
crumble because you believe in them and
I think you've got to lean in my friend
you gotta go this is what I believe I'm
gonna stand up for it I'm gonna fight
for it and if it crumbles it crumbles
but I've done my best I think that's the
answer to your question I think it's a
very good point yeah shut up Round of
Applause
[Applause]
uh very very finely I mean my two
pennant is that I mean don't have an
identity crisis it's got nothing to do
with your identities to do with your
what you believe what you think what
your politics are and it's broader than
your personal identity uh I'm Welsh but
I very rarely tell you that because it's
got nothing to do with anybody and it
plays a very small part in my life uh
I'm more interested in democracy and
political ideas
um that said
um I also think that that the name
Progressive which is where we started
the conversation is such now an abused
term because everybody who's Progressive
and says that they are are the most
reactionary [ __ ] you could ever come
across right so I think we need to
either like I say reclaim some of these
words or use them in a different
different formulation uh because I think
we need to understand what progress
means progress development as you say
about environmentalism it's about
development not sustainable development
it's about really kind of humanity being
put first so I'm a great believer in
that but it also means reclaiming the
idea of Marx because because no no not
because I'm trying to convince you be
marxists but I'm saying that there is an
abuse of the idea of what I've heard
today is just not what Marxism is
um but on that note thank you all very
much for coming very very generous of
you to ask your questions Round of
Applause thank you guys thank you
if you don't have it
on the bookstore now
[Music]